hello everybody someone was kind enough
to give me four beta keys to the
planetside 2 beta and since the game
launches in a week I wanted to give them
out really quickly so here's the deal
either take my happy wheels highlights
video or the fall of slender man video
and you share that on facebook and
twitter send me an email with a picture
of the share I'll get your name in the
bucket and one day from now just to give
people time tomorrow i will do a drawing
real quick that's like the shortest
giveaway I've ever gotten but I've got
these four keys that I just want to get
out the door so I'll share the videos
each one counts as a share up to two per
person because there's the two videos
links in the description below for the
videos that you can share um and that's
it so good luck thanks for sharing and
thanks for helping out the channel and I
hope you have fun whoever wins the
planetside 2 beta keys bye bye